You think you're happy?
I'm happy. I'm very happy.
What we will do, today is wrap up
phase diagrams,
make some comments about the final
exam, and then we're going to get
some people that aren't associated
with class are going to come in,
they will pass out paperwork and do
the course evaluations.
And, we'll get you out of here at
11:55. Before I go any further,
draw your attention to another IAP
subject.
If you're looking for something to
do during January,
and this will be offered by myself
and my postdoc,
Patrick Trapa. We are going to
offer a lab subject without a lab.
It's part of an experiment that we
are conducting for the National
Science Foundation to see if large
classes such as these that don't
have a lab experience can get much
of the lab experience,
that is to say, planning for
discovery, preparation of the
background information,
and then mining the data from data
sets that are in the public domain,
and then analyzing the data and then
presenting the data.
All of that you get without turning
the knobs. And,
that's about three quarters of a lab
experience. So,
I think three quarters is better
than none. That's what we want to
try to do. It's a limited
enrollment of 20 people,
and it's going to run for two weeks
during IAP in the mornings,
and you can go to the IAP website.
And, it's worth six credits as well.
So, OK, enough said about that.
My office hours,
I'll have a little bit of extended
office hours Friday 4:00-6:00,
next Tuesday 4:00-6:00. And, there
will be a question and answer
session on the evening of Tuesday,
the 14th of December. Professor
Ballinger is going to run that in
54-100. All of these,
and I know the TAs, some of them are
going to run review sessions.
All of these are optional. They
have strict instructions not to
teach new material.
If you don't want to go to those,
you don't have to. If you want to,
bring your questions, and I just
want to make it totally
value neutral.
OK, last day we talked about phase
diagrams. I want to continue the
discussion today.
We looked at type one,
which involves very nearly similar
materials. So,
that gives a lenticular phase
diagram shown here.
And, then we looked at type two
where we have a phase separation
without change of phase,
giving us a miscibility gap.
Remember, whenever you're in a
two-phase regime,
two-phase regime, queen of diamonds,
bingo, that means tie line, lever
rule.
So, phase separation will give us a
single phase, whether it's a
homogeneous solid solution breaking
into two phases,
or a homogeneous liquid solution
breaking into two phases.
Those two phases have different
compositions, and the compositions
of each of those two phases is given
by the end members of the tie line.
And the relative amounts of the two
phases is given by the lever rule.
Today I want to look at type three.
And type three is characterized by
sort of a mix of the two.
And on the left,
we have change of state,
and on the right, we have no change
of state. On the left,
we have perfect solubility.
On the right we have partial
solubility. So,
we're going to take the solubility
characteristics of type two,
and the change of state from type
one, and put them together.
And that's what we end up with as
the overarching features here.
And, this is what the phase diagram
looks like, where we have something
that's similar to,
you see the bottom here?
The bottom here looks like that
syncline.
And the top here looks like the
beginning of the lens.
So, we have liquid, and then beta
here. Beta is a solid solution,
alpha is a solid solution. So,
let's designate those.
Alpha is a solid solution of A and
B, only it's A rich.
It's very near pure A,
but it's not exactly pure A.
So, this is homogeneous solid
solution just as you'd have in a
lenticular diagram.
And, beta is a solid solution of A
and B, only it's B rich.
And L, that's a liquid solution.
That's a liquid solution of A and B.
So, these are all single phase.
These are all single phase. Let's
put that up here.
This is P equals one,
single phase. This is P equals one,
single phase. And, this is P equals
one, single phase.
Now, if I want to go from one
single phase to another single phase,
I have to go through
a two-phase regime.
So, this is slush,
liquid plus solid alpha.
This is slush, liquid plus solid
beta, and now I have a solid
solution on the right.
I have a solid solution on the left,
and I can't go from one single phase
regime to another single phase
regime. I had to go through a
two-phase regime.
So, this is alpha plus beta.
And, now I've got two phases down
here, one phase here.
Look at this point here that I've
indicated in purple. What is this?
This is a special.
This is alpha, beta,
and liquid in equilibrium.
And, this is called the eutectic.
It's the equilibrium between solid
alpha, solid beta,
and liquid. And, this type of
diagram is called a eutectic diagram.
It's a eutectic diagram,
and it has some remarkable
properties that make it advantageous
in processing.
Look at here in the type one
diagram.
There's no point on the type one
diagram where we see all liquid
below the melting point of the lower
of the two components.
We essentially have a lens
extending from the lower melting
point to the higher melting point.
If you look here, if I add A to B,
the melting point drops. We go down
this liquidus.
That's not surprising.
What's surprising in the case of
the eutectic is when you add B to A,
the melting point drops.
So, we get freezing point depression
from both ends with the result that,
you see this whole liquid zone in
here? This whole liquid zone has
liquid lying at temperatures below
the lower melting point.
So, this gives us a much,
much greater range in which to
process. So, we have a depressed
liquid region.
So, let's call this the
characteristic is freezing point
depression of both components,
of both A and B, which is something
we didn't see in the case
of the lenticular.
And this eutectic point is the
equilibrium of alpha,
beta, and liquid. And,
it's unique. It exists at only one
value of temperature and composition.
So, that's unique to every
particular system.
So, let's look at some examples.
So, here's one apropos of the coming
winter. This is water and ethylene
glycol. And, we talked about water
ethylene glycol in the coolant
system with reference to controlling
boil over. And,
as the winter is coming,
we want to avoid freezing of water
in the channels of the engine block
because the water is going to freeze
from the outside in.
That means the last water to freeze
will already be plugged by ice at
the ends. And,
as you know, when water freezes,
it expands. How do you know? You
know for the negative slope
on the PT diagram.
And, that expansion is so
energy-laden that it'll crack the
iron of the engine block.
So, you have to keep the water from
freezing. So,
what we can do is we can add a
second component and give ourselves
a eutectic type system.
So, here's pure water on the left.
Here's pure ethylene glycol on the
right. It's a double alcohol.
There is the chemical formula for
it. And so, pure water,
which we see the melting point of
pure water is 0¡C.
And, what this is showing is that
this alpha region of ethylene glycol,
and water is so narrow that for all
intents and purposes this appears as
a straight line.
That's why you go automatically
from seemingly pure water to this
eutectic regime.
So, if we add, typically,
about 50 volume percent ethylene
glycol, that's the recommended
mixture, what do we see?
We see we get freezing point
depression down to about -35 or so
Celsius which ought to take care of
most driving needs.
Now, if you want,
you can get maximum freezing point
protection by adding about two
thirds. In other words,
68 volume percent glycol gives you a
eutectic at -69¡C,
or -92¡F. That ought to take care
of everybody in this room.
I don't know anybody here that's
driving when it's more than -92¡F.
So that should be OK. But, if you
want to be an enthusiast and decide
I'm not a cheapskate; I'm going to
use pure ethylene glycol.
Why dilute it with water?
Well, pure ethylene glycol freezes
at about, here it is.
This is the Fahrenheit scale here.
We are talking about cars after all.
So, it freezes at,
what is it, about 10¡F,
all right? And then, adding water
to glycol gives you the freezing
point depression here.
So, actually if you go beyond two
thirds glycol,
one third water,
the freezing point is actually
rising. So, that's not
such a smart idea.
The second thing is,
here are the chemical properties of
some of these.
And, you see here is glycol -13¡
Celsius is the freezing point.
But, look at here. The viscosity
of water is roughly one in units of
centipoise. And,
the viscosity of ethylene glycol at
20¡C is 21. It's 21 times the
viscosity of water.
And, you know the viscosity is a
transport property much like
diffusion. And so,
it has an Arrhenius temperature
dependence.
So, if we get the temperature down
to, say, -10¡C this is so highly
viscous that you run the risk of
burning out your water pump.
So, bottom line is don't do
something stupid and run high
intensity glycol.
Here, I've plotted both the
solid-liquid equilibrium and
liquid-vapor equilibrium.
And, this is one of the few times
when nature has been kind to us.
When we add 50% glycol to water,
we get the freezing point depression
down to about -35¡C.
And we get boiling point elevation.
So, what we've done is we've taken
this interval of liquid water which
is at purity is 100¡C.
I haven't put the pressure cap on.
If I just use 1 atmosphere pressure,
water freezes at zero Celsius and
boils at 100 Celsius.
If I add 50% glycol, it freezes at
-35 Celsius and boils at about 106¡C.
So now, I've widened
the liquid regime.
And then, if I put the pressure cap
on, then this line is going to move.
These lines don't move at all for 1
atmosphere pressure.
That's why we can throw away the
pressure variable.
So, by changing pressure and
composition we are able to widen the
liquid range and thereby protect
against boil over and protect
against freeze out.
Remember, boiling, we want to make
sure we have good heat transfer.
Here's one that's used in keeping
things safe in the wintertime.
This is ice, and this is the
water-sodium chloride phase diagram:
again, a eutectic diagram.
And, if you add sodium chloride,
you will extend the liquid range.
And so, we sprinkle salt on walkways
and roadways in order to melt the
ice and make the roads and sidewalks
safe in giving us some traction.
And what I've done is I've
color-coded all of these so that you
will know liquidus,
solidus, and, oh, we've got a new
one here. This is
called the solvus.
This line here is called solvus.
You already know this is liquidus.
We met liquidus last day and we met
solidus last day.
There are old friends.
But here's a new friend,
solvus. So, I've got all these
diagrams. I've color-coded them the
same way and I've written the
equilibrium for you.
So, if you add salt to water,
you can get down to about -21¡C.
And, notice that it's an almost 0¡F.
In fact, Daniel Fahrenheit
determined the baseline of the
Fahrenheit temperature scale by
putting salt in water.
He used ammonium chloride.
And, ammonium chloride in water
gave a minimum at what he calibrated
as 0¡F. And then,
he took body temperature by putting
his thermometer,
he was a maker thermometers in
Amsterdam, very good glassmaker who
could put mercury in glass
thermometers, he put the thermometer
under his wife's armpit, and
she came out at 96¡F.
She was running a little bit cool,
all right? And so, he said, OK,
that will be 96 units,
and then water is 32. And the
boiling point of water is 212,
and so on. And then subsequently we
went to the Celsius scale.
We don't use sodium chloride on the
walks. We use calcium chloride.
And you can see why. Calcium
chloride gives us a greater freezing
point depression.
Sodium chloride in many instances
would not be that effective.
So, most of the stuff you see
thrown on the roads is calcium
chloride, potassium chloride.
If you are hypertense and you want
to use potassium chloride and avoid
sodium, is not going to help you
much. You won't get hypertension,
but you'll fall down because the
walks will be slippery.
So, you'll have other problems to
worry about, but that's the way you
take your mind off the hypertension.
You've got a broken hip. Oh, he's
mean. Why is he saying that?
OK, the holidays are coming.
Here's zirconia.
Zirconia, remember zirconia at room
temperature is monoclinic.
And that's no good. Cubic zirconia
is stable only at very high
temperatures. But look at this.
If we add calcium oxide to zirconia,
we have this huge range. It's a
eutectic system.
There's the eutectic.
But en route, we stabilize the
cubic form all the way down to room
temperature. So,
when you are buying a stabilized
zirconia, meaning that the cubic
form has been stabilized,
that's the one that's got the high
refractive index.
And again, liquidus,
solidus, solvus. And,
look, it's a single phase regime.
It must be bounded by two phase
regime. So, if I look to the right,
it's cubic zirconia, solid solution
plus calcium zirconate.
If I go to the left,
it's a zirconia calcia solid
solution with another tetragonal
form. So, again,
the model is, if you're moving
across a multicomponent,
two component phase diagram,
single phase bounds dual phase,
bounds single phase, bounds dual
phase, bounds single phase,
bounds dual phase. This is really
fantastic stuff.
Oh, this is good.
Aluminum magnesium: this is the
beverage can.
This is the beverage can.
So, we're looking at it. It's a
eutectic system.
So, we're going to add a few
percent of magnesium into aluminum,
which is going to put us here: alpha
solid solution.
If we have too much,
we end up in a two phase regime,
and that's no good because when we
go to deform the can,
it will tear. The metal will tear.
So, we have to have single phase,
freezing point depression.
And then, this is important in
metal recycling.
We want to be able to process this
stuff, and energy is costly.
So, if we can process at lower
temperatures, it's advantageous.
This is a very important one for
microelectronics.
This is lead 10. Lead melts at 327.
Tin melts at 222 Celsius.
And, there is a eutectic down at
183. I learned this in high school.
We had this industrial arts class.
It was 374¡F is the eutectic point
of soft solder.
I'll know that on my deathbed.
So, what does this tell us?
It tells us that if you are building
a micro device,
whether it's a cell phone or
computer, you've got to solder in
all the lead wires.
And, when you solder,
you have to energize the system.
You have to melt the solder, and
then it has to bond to the metal and
then freeze. And every time you go
in with that energy source,
you heat not only the solder but you
heat everything else.
And, you know, if you're making a
P-N junction, you want it sharp.
But, what happens if you heat a
sharp positional gradient?
Diffusion will occur,
and diffusion increases as
temperature rises.
So, you are looking for a solder
that has the lowest melting point
possible so that you can get in and
out doing minimal thermal damage.
In fact, when you design one of
these large devices,
you have in your design scheme a
thermal budget.
And, you look at processing routes
that consume less energy not only
because you want to be energy
efficient from a manufacturing
standpoint, but because every time
you put joules of energy in,
you run the risk of having more and
more diffusion.
And, those sharp P-N junctions will
become diffuse P-N junctions.
And, as our feature size is getting
smaller and smaller,
the diffusion distances are shorter
and shorter and you've got less time
before you've blurred those
interfaces and then the device is
useless. So, right now,
there is a huge effort to look at
lead free solders.
Lead, mercifully, has this low
melting eutectic below 200¡C.
That's the good news. The bad news
is its lead. And so,
now we've got two alternatives.
And that's something you're going to
be faced with.
Either we have something that is
lead free and very costly,
more costly than the device itself,
or we have something that is not
terribly effective.
It cold freezes in the joint and
the joints pop off,
and so on. So, this is a eutectic
diagram indicating the value of
freezing point depression in
processing. Last day I showed you
how to use compositional variation.
Let's look at how we make silicon.
This is the iron-silicon
phase diagram.
Iron-silicon phase diagram is a
little bit messy but I draw your
attention to the top right corner.
Unfortunately, this one is drawn
the other way around; it's got iron
on the left and silicon on the right.
And, I want to draw your attention
to dilute concentrations of iron in
silicon. So, we've normally been
looking at things from the left.
But I think you're capable of
flipping that around in your mind.
And what do you notice? You notice
that the alpha region of iron in
silicon isn't present there.
That is to say that there is only a
tiny, tiny solubility
for iron in silicon.
So, if we want to purify,
remember, we are starting with
something really cheap.
We are starting with beach sand,
and we need to go to five nines,
that is, 99.999% purity.
And, iron is death to a silicon
microdevice. We've got to get the
iron out. One of the ways to get
iron out is to start with something
in the liquid.
So, this is pure iron over here,
pardon me, this is pure silicon over
on the left side.
So I've turned that phase diagram
around: pure silicon,
and this is percent iron.
And, I want to get the iron out.
And, I'm not going to boil the
stuff off and use fractional
distillation. These things are too
high melting. They melt at such
high temperatures.
They boil at such high temperatures.
I don't know what I contain them in.
So, what we can do,
so this melting point of silicon.
It's the melting point of pure
silicon which is about 1,430¡.
What I could do as I could take some.
Let's say this is C naught; the
original impurity level of iron in
silicon. What I can do is I can
cool this melt down into the
two-phase regime and hold.
And, what happens if I hold it in
the two-phase regime?
This is alpha. This is liquid.
So, this must be slush. Alpha plus
liquid: it's going to phase separate.
And, what do I see?
The solid phase here has a value of
iron at CS, which is
less than C naught.
So, the solid has less iron in it.
It's a higher purity silicon. And
the liquid has C;.
And, what do we find?
We see that CS is less than C
naught is less than Cl.
And, this is the lowest value of
iron. So now,
I can take this stuff out,
throw it into another furnace,
melt it, and cool it. And, what
happens? As I did with the
distillation, I keep chasing it up.
Now, granted, I lose a lot of
material. But,
I'm gaining material that has very,
very low levels. So, again, what's
happening is that this phase
separation leads to compositional
differentiation.
And, that's the paradigm:
compositional differentiation.
So, we can do it with
differentiation.
We can do this with liquid vapor and
do a distillation,
or we can do it this way,
which is a solidification.
So, this is the impurity. The iron
is a solute impurity,
and we say what is happening in this
process is the iron impurity is
being rejected up into the liquid
phase. So, when we are holding here,
what we have is,
remember, the silicon is less dense
than its liquid.
So, this is high purity silicon,
high purity, and this is low purity
silicon liquid.
Now, if I take this,
throw it into another furnace,
melt it, I can do it over and over
again. So, this is called zone
melting. I'll show you how that
works, where people speed the whole
thing up. You take a giant salami
of silicon, which now the standard
is 12 inches in diameter.
So, this thing is a single crystal
of silicon, 12 inches in diameter,
and several meters long. So, we're
not going to take that single
crystal and remelt it.
What we can do instead is put some
induction coils around it.
We put induction coils around it
and send a current through it,
what will happen as this will get so
hot that it will melt.
And by surface tension forces,
I can contain the molten zone here.
And, what happens if I hold this
long enough? I eventually drop the
temperature and I get phase
separation. So,
on one side, I'm going to get
accumulation of the impurity.
And then, I can drag this through
and sweep all the impurities down to
one end and chop that end off.
And, then I could do it again.
I say, well, why do it again? Why
don't I just have another set of
coils like this,
and then another set of coils like
this? And so,
this stuff melts,
freezes, melts, freezes,
melts, freezes. All the garbage
gets sent down to the end,
chop this off, and now we have five
nines silicon exploiting the
compositional differentiation in
that two phase regime.
So, that's really good,
yeah. So, this is used in scrap
metal processing.
It's used in making high purity
silicon. If you ever find yourself
in the North Atlantic,
you could use this for desalination
because you know that it's,
if you looked at that phase diagram,
what you have is the composition of
ice and salt water is very nearly
pure water. There's very little
salt content. So,
this is called zone melting or zone
refining.
Zone melting is the technique.
Zone refining is the result. We
get the purity up.
OK, so now let's look at another
use of this. Let's look at a use of
this in the context of champagne,
and at the same time honor an
inventor. So,
the person I want to talk about is
Madame Nicole Barbe Ponsardin.
And, she was a young lady who
married Francois Clicquot of the
Clicquot family that owns a large
champagne winery.
And she was widowed at the age of 27
in an act that was atypical of
French women in her day.
Instead of just receding and being
a silent partner,
letting the winery go about its
business, she took control of the
winery and really became very
aggressive about how this one should
be made. So, she did all these
things, which was unheard of by
anybody at the time marketing
champagne to the courts of Europe
and making the myth that champagne
is this magical beverage.
It was drunk only in pretty much
France at the time,
bought lands in the best vineyards
to control the chemistry.
This is all about chemical control
the product, fought fiercely against
counterfeiting,
used the court system to prosecute
people who sold wine masquerading as
champagne, strict quality control
procedures, all of the sort of thing,
making sure that the chemistry is
under control,
produced the first Rosé champagne,
again, good chemistry, leaving the
skin on the juice and then oversaw
this invention of a new technology,
which brings together phase diagrams.
That's what I'm talking about it.
You think I'm talking about it just
because I want to talk about
champagne. This is an application
of phase diagrams.
So, first of all: the problem.
The problem is that back in the
late 1700s, champagne was cloudy.
Champagne was cloudy. That's why
the champagne glasses have all the
cut facets on them,
so you obscure the cloudiness of the
beverage. It was actually ugly.
It bubbled, but it was very cloudy.
Why? Well, we need some chemistry.
To make champagne, or to make any
wine, you start with sugar and you
react with yeast.
Yeast attacks the sugar,
liberating CO2, and converting sugar
to alcohol. And,
it's a one-stop shopping.
Everything is on the grape.
The sugar is in the grape juice and
the yeast is in the grape skin.
So you just press it and stand back.
OK, but there are some other
byproducts of this reaction.
And these are various insolubles.
So, when this stuff is sitting in a
big barrel and CO2 is bubbling out
and alcohol is being created,
there is all this solid stuff that's
coming out of the grape pulp.
And so, some of it sits to the
bottom automatically.
And some of it is suspended.
And so, if we want to treat this
stuff, you've got to either use
chemical coagulants to get these
fine particles that are in
suspension to grow too large enough
size that they'll gravity
settle. Or you siphon.
And this is the typical way with
wines. Well, you can't siphon a
champagne or you will lose all the
bubbles because you keep the lid on
the barrel and that's what traps the
CO2. So, if you open the barrel to
siphon, you lose all the gas and now
you end up with flat champagne.
So, up until 1800 people would just
put the stuff in a bottle,
put the cork on, trapp the CO2,
and then when you went to pour the
champagne, all the sediment would
come off the bottom,
which explains why the bottle looks
like this. It's got these deep ruts
so that you can keep as much of the
sludge on the bottom.
But, it's gassing,
and this stuff gets churned up and
so on. By the way,
while I'm talking about this,
I can't do this without teaching you
how to chill champagne using heat
transfer. So: how not to chill
champagne. How not to do it: this
is how most people do it,
but you're 3.091ers, so you know how
not to do it. You do not
simply put ice on it.
This is lousy heat transfer because
what do we have here?
Here's the glass of the bottle and
here's chunks of ice.
So this is probably, I don't know,
-5¡C, and there's all this air in
here. And, the air is at room
temperature. So,
this is sloppy. So what should we
do instead? Will we are going to do
instead is we're going to use the
ice-water phase diagram.
We are going to flood this with
water. And now,
I'm going to have intimate liquid
solid contact.
And this thing will be thermostatted
(sic) at 0¡C because that you know
from the P-T diagram.
That's where it is.
And that's how you chill anything.
You chill your soda, your fruit
juice, heat transfer.
So, she had the idea: how are we
going to get rid of all this sludge?
She says, turn the bottles upside
down. And in fact she knew the
optimum angle was 45¡.
And then, have people turn the
bottle so that the sludge spirals
its way down into the underside of
the plug of the bottle.
And, this is called remuer,
to turn. And, there are people that
spend their lives doing this,
quarter turn, quarter turn, quarter
turn, quarter turn.
And then you say,
well, that's really dumb.
How is she going to get the sludge
out from underneath the cap of the
bottle? Well,
look at this phase diagram.
If you mix salt with water,
you get a brine that freezes at
-21¡C. And, if you intersect that
with the phase diagram of alcohol
water, there is about 10% alcohol in
champagne. That will freeze at a
temperature a little bit higher.
So, what will happen is you will
make an ice plug in the neck of the
bottle by immersing the bottle
upside-down in brine.
So, it's the marriage of this and
the knowledge of the phase
separation in the liquidus regime.
You form solid ice starting at 0¡C.
So, you form an ice plug here in
the neck of the bottle.
And then, all you do after the ice
plug has formed,
what you can do is turn this right
side up. You undo the cork.
It heats from the outside in.
As soon as you get a skim coat of
water on the outside,
the pressure blows the cork out,
takes all the sludge. You quickly
recap it, and now you have
clarified champagne.
And that's how every bottle of
champagne is made to this day thanks
to her invention.
It's positively brilliant.
So, here's the summary of it.
You contain the lees in the plug of
ice just before disgorgement and let
this go. Now,
the French are very traditional.
They still have people turning
quarter turn, but there are a few
wineries that have given in to
mechanization.
And they have this large device
that actually shakes all the bottles
that are set at 45¡ angles.
And they call this gyropalette.
In the California champagne
wineries, they also have such a
thing. It's called VLM,
which stands, I kid you not,
this is California, very large
machine. [LAUGHTER] Dude,
very large machine, dude. All right,
so if you understand this phase
diagram you know what's
going on in here.
All right, now let me say a few
words about the final exam.
I'm going to let this thing chill,
and then what I'm going to do, I'll
make a few personal observations.
Once I open that bottle, the class
is over. So that's the way it's
going to work.
Right, so the final exam is on the
15th in the morning,
Johnson Athletic Center.
Be there at nine o'clock.
Don't show up late. Three hours:
but not three times the work of a
monthly test. Intensive coverage
since test three,
and extensive coverage of everything
else. You get one aid sheet,
not one and a half, not two, one.
One 8.5 x 11, bring your periodic
table, your table of constants,
calculator, and something to write
with.
So, there's the five items: aid
sheet, periodic table,
table of constants, calculator,
and pen, always the same five items.
I'm not going to do anything
different from the monthly tests,
about comparable difficulty. It's
redemptory. I want you to pass.
You got to show me you've learned
something. Read the entire exam,
show your work, solve algebraically,
try not to waste time on
intermediate calculations.
Remain confident; don't give up
because you feel your first couple
of questions aren't going your way.
Just stay there.
You've paid your price of admission.
Sit there for three hours.
It's warm. Academic honesty:
there's going to be 600 of us in the
Johnson Athletic Center.
Keep your eyes on your own work.
I do not want to have any episodes
involving academic dishonesty.
And, believe me, several years ago
I had a couple fellows that decided
that the strength of two is greater
than one. And,
I ended up having to bring him
before the committee on discipline,
which took a huge amount of my time,
which I was not happy about, and one
of those people did not return for
his sophomore year.
It's a dumb price to pay for a class
that's a pass-no-record class.
Do your best, but do your own.
Overall grade scheme is based on
many factors including trends.
So, those of you who have a hard
time at the beginning,
if I see an emergence, and I'm not
saying you have to write a 95 on the
final to compensate for
a 30 on the first test.
But if I see that you've made the
effort, and learning is happening,
your TA can vouch for you, I'm
inclined to pass you.
Look, if I take the batteries out
of this watch,
it's right twice a day.
Give me something to point to.
Give me some thing to point to.
But you can't tell me that you
understood the material but you
never passed one thing.
And if you're going to pass one
thing, I'd recommend it be the final.
And, by the way,
I'm looking at the other trend,
too that if I see people who think
that, hey, I only need a two on the
final and I'll get a 50,
and you somehow don't make the 50
even though you had a passing grade
going on the final, you're gone.
You are gone because that says to me
you gave up; you stop learning at
around Veterans Day.
So, I think it's brinkmanship to
decide you're going to go on the
final and maybe just answer one or
two questions and leave.
But, I leave the choice up to you.
I don't tell people how to live
their lives, but I will make you
aware of the consequences of a
really bad final.
It doesn't look good.
You can have your exam papers back.
We should have them graded.
And you should have them available
to you by Friday afternoon.
Don't come and see us before then.
We are busy grading. We are busy
tabulating grades.
There will be a grades meeting on
Friday morning.
We'll discuss all the cases.
I go through everything. There's
no time limit for appeals,
but I assure you, if someone is
going to get a grade that's not
going to pass them,
I'm going to personally go through
that paper, make sure there's no
clerical errors,
check the grading,
work with the TA's; we're not going
to fail somebody because,
gee, I thought that was a three.
It looks like it's an eight.
Oh, too bad. No, we're going to
make sure it's done right.
So, we will be very careful.
And you can bring them back in the
regrades if you want but I will put
some security measures in place.
The practice of erasing answers and
rewriting them is not a smart thing
to do because what happens is,
you have terrible taste. You have
terrible taste.
I'm drinking champagne.
[LAUGHTER] [APPLAUSE]
Now, I case of champagne,
I would have said, quel finesse,
but this, sauvage. OK, so, to deal
with the possible eventuality that
somebody in a moment of weakness
might erase something,
we're going to indiscriminately
photocopy about 5% of the exams.
So, if you decide you want to erase
something and bring it in and get it
regraded, the question you've got to
ask yourself is, do you
feel lucky? [LAUGHTER]
Do you? All right,
so this is 3.091. We've gone a long
way, you know?
We started a long time ago,
bonding structure and went through
the different types of bonding
structure properties.
A lot of learning went on in this
class. Stability,
instability, chemical reactions,
diffusion, phase transformations,
and now phase diagrams. So, I want
to make a few personal observations
and say that you should be proud of
what you've learned.
This was an ambitious syllabus,
and I'm convinced that people are
going to have something that they
can move on to their majors with
next year. Secondly,
I want to wish you much success on
the final. I'm not out to fail
anybody. I love to pass everybody,
but you've got to give me something
to point to. And I've given you as
much information as I can about how
to succeed on the final.
But, if worse comes to worst and
you don't make it,
what's the worst thing that happens?
You are required to withdraw from
the Institute. So what?
Remember one thing: that no grade
that anybody gives you here is a
commentary on your value as a human
being. Look, I have no degrees from
this place. I feel great.
The third thing I want to say is
I've been teaching at MIT for 27
years. This is my 27th year,
and I'd never enjoyed teaching as
much as I had this year.
You've really been a joy to teach.
I can't believe I said that with a
straight face. [LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
I want to thank my staff,
my TA is, my tutors, administrators.
I had Hillary and Lori helping,
Professor Ballinger who subbed for
me when I had a chance to go up to
Halifax and give a lecture about 3.
91. The audiovisual texts and the
fellows outside from the academic
media production group that takes
the videos and gets them up on the
web so that you can avoid coming to
class, I mean,
review what you failed to catch the
first time round as
you paid attention.
And, I guess the last thing I wanted
to do before we can get to the
champagne and the course evaluation
is Dwayne Daughtry is here from my
department's academic office.
Actually, Dwayne, you're free to
start distributing those forms.
There is one more chemistry lesson
that we had to get to,
and that is, we talked about four
types of primary bonds: ionic,
covalent, metallic, and van der
Waals. Well, there is a fifth type
of primary bond,
and that's the kind of bond that's
been forming in this room
for the past 14 weeks.
As a bond between people,
and it's a very special kind of bond
because it has the property of,
can never be broken. And, so you
say, well that sounds kind of sappy
and so on. Yeah,
it does, because a student came up
with it. I didn't come up with it.
I've been teaching a core graduate
class in materials science
for about ten years.
I was at a conference and I saw
these two people standing.
One of them was from industry,
and one of them I taught here at MIT.
It was an alum.
I go up and say hello,
and the fellow from industry says,
hey, do you know so and so? And I
said, yeah, of course.
He was a student of mine at MIT.
I was his kinetics professor. And,
the student says, excuse me,
Professor Sadoway,
it's true. You taught me kinetics,
but please don't say you were my
kinetics professor.
You will always be my kinetics
professor.
And I went, whoa.
[LAUGHTER] I mean,
he came up with that.
So, now the tables are turned,
and now it's time for you to move on.
So, I know that you're going to do
something remarkable in your
professional lives.
I hope it's remarkably wonderful
and not remarkably stupid,
but, you know, at some point people
might ask you,
where did you learn your chemistry?
You'll have to say Sadoway at MIT.
So, whether you like it or not,
I will always be your chemistry
professor. And now I want to find
out what's going on inside here.
So, first, we have to open this.
So, take the wire off, the mesh off,
[LAUGHTER]. Tenure means never
having to say you're
sorry. [LAUGHTER]
27 years I've been doing this.
Now, how many turns in a wire
basket? One, two,
three, four, five, six,
always six. Six turns of the wire
basket. There's Vive Clicole.
Her image is on the top in honor.
We'll put it at a 45 degree angle
and turn it ever so slightly.
Beautiful. Soft, not this,
vulgarity. That's what goes on in
football locker rooms.
So, now, I've been waiting 14 weeks
for this. So,
this is the CO2 out gassing,
you know that phase diagram. It's
all about phase diagrams,
put that back on ice. So,
when Dom Perignon first drank
champagne, he said,
I feel as though I'm drinking stars.
He's right. Okay, the class is
over. [APPLAUSE]